sometimes I imagine myself as a let's
say a Russian peasant in the 19th
century and how the patterns in which
people were living were so naive they
were true a lot of them were true and
were real but they were very innocent
and so in some ways they were in very
much in danger and so when the
materialist secularist narrative comes
in people get crushed you know and and I
saw that even when I was young I would
see people with a very confident but
naive faith and then they would go to
university and then they would just get
crushed and they would go to their first
philosophy class and they would just be
completely demolished because they had
never heard anything like this and never
heard any of these arguments and never
thought about any of these things in
Quebec we we had to think of sejet and
they had philosophy classes in sijap and
I think those philosophy classes were
even just designed to like slash the
Catholicism out of all the quebecers
that went through that in the 70s when
they were installed and it worked like
it totally work the people came in these
naive little church Growers and then
were completely destroyed but what's
interesting so now we go through this
Loop and now we come to let's say this
movement this symbolic understanding
people kind of re-understanding the role
of perception of attention and how it
shapes our narratives how it shapes the
way the reality manifests itself and
once people have gone through that that
training what are you gonna how are you
gonna take that away from them how are
those philosophy professors going to
take that away from them I don't think
it's possible anymore like I I always
say it's like I don't there's nothing
you could tell me I don't I mean maybe I
don't know I don't I feel like I've
heard it all like I feel like there's
what is it that you're going to tell me
that you're going to convince me no back
into that old world I don't see it
happening I don't see it happening
either
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
I do agree like I think that the change
that that's happening and I think John
rubiki also has that Insight is that the
change of perspective or world view
that's happening right now it's it's
Monumental and so you know it is almost
I think it's going to be like equivalent
to to something like the enlightenment
or maybe the Renaissance in the sense
that the shift that happened
and once the shift has totally happened
for most people it's just going to
become the water they live in they won't
be aware of the change I think there's a
few people that are aware of the change
they kind of see it happening and it's
actually painful in some ways because
you can almost feel it it was happening
to me like I was really feeling it
painfully during
in 2016 2017 it was very it was painful
I was I was sensing like the whole
tectonic plates under my feet shifting
and it was happening in many ways some
of it was political because of the Trump
election and and all of the craziness
online and and these this kind of
Madness around what Jordan was going
through and everything but while that
was happening I could really feel
the world shifting under my feet and it
was it was like a kind of existential
suffering you know it was hard to
describe to people but it was almost
like
like you feel like you're being ripped
apart and you and you and you and and so
I felt that now I don't feel it so much
um because I feel like at least many
people kind of bridged the the to the
other side of the change so I I don't
feel alone too because one of the things
that happened for a while is that my
brother and I we just felt alone like we
we had this kind of intuition about how
the world functioned and it was like
there was no one around us who who could
talk about it but now
it's as if now it's become
yeah it's it's it's obvious and there
are all these people that I think it's
almost like these things were preparing
themselves in secret for a long time
different players you're like John was
thinking about it and Jordan and all
these other people were thinking about
things and trying to bring them together
then suddenly the moment you know that
Kairos moment kind of happened then it
just snapped together and then we kind
of found each other and so that's a
that's pretty that's pretty wild you
know it is it's interesting that you say
that too because I had that sense too
that there's almost like this long
Preparatory period this sort of
gestation that something was
Subterranean for a long time and it was
kind of it was being formed invisibly I
think and when you look back you can see
it it's like you look back and you're
like oh you know I think Heidegger was
talked
Heidegger was talking about this stuff
like all the things that were kind of
Interest interests us you think well
actually there there are some of the
modernists that seem to have been
intuiting some of it and sometimes a
little crookedly or sometimes a little
strangely
and so and so then but now it feels like
it's Landing let's say whatever it is
those insights that were that that
they're landing and they're becoming
obvious you know and so something like
let's say the way that Heidegger
described the experience of of the world
was something that was just completely
obtuse just completely obscure for most
people like what is it it's just
gibberish they'd read Heidegger and
they're like they're just gibberish or
even the postmodern like actually does
have a phenomenological perspective he
his all his thinking is is based on that
phenomenological perspective so his
categories
are he emphasizes the margin and you
know the exception and the dissemination
but he does it from that perspective and
so now it's as if it's all kind of
landing and now you can I can talk to a
regular person
and we found language to say it to
someone just a regular guy and he's like
yeah okay all right no I I like they get
it you know and yeah yeah I think that's
astounding it is astounding it is
astounding and I think it requires I
think it's to your point about the
Kairos I think one of the features as I
understand it of Kairos is that it
requires a certain kind of a certain
synchronistic alignment of a lot of
patterns to become concentric
in such a way that there's an opening
there's actually something through which
all of this to travel and I think it has
something to do with the fact that
I think what happens within an
individual person is something like
what's happening more broadly which is
that you just you have to go through
this period of suffering such that you
exhaust yourself you exhaust yourself
beyond the limits of what was
tenable and right it's like somehow I'm
coming up against the frame of the world
that I held
and it's just not there's no purchase
anymore it's like breath is gone it's
finished it's dried up it's like the
purgation right it's like something's
finished I've reached the end point of
myself Beyond which there is just
nothing yeah and I it's almost as though
you have to get to that point maybe
whether we're speaking of a person an
individual or we're speaking of
in a more communal sense right I guess
they're co-extensive right that's the
whole point of the synchronicity is that
the individual in the communal have a
co-extensive pattern and that it has
something to do with reaching the end of
a period of suffering that exhausts
whatever the worldview was that was
doing the gripping and now it can't grip
anymore and some it's like transform or
die it's almost like there are two
choices yeah like that happening I feel
that's what a sense I'm getting from you
I think so I think so I it seems like I
think Saint Paul talks about that you
know we talked about this idea of the
the birth pangs you know the world is in
birth Banks and that I I think this is
almost like a fractal thing like it's
something that happens all the time at
different levels like you said in
individually and and there's this sense
like you said a pregation or that the
suffering and the breakdown has to
has to happen before the the new world
is born you know
um and sometimes it's
I mean sometimes it's pretty painful
like I I really I think for example that
necessarily painful probably yeah well
interestingly enough it feels like I've
always thought that the plague had
probably a lot to do with the copernican
revolution like it took a while for the
plague to to where the effects of the
plague to kind of lead to a change of
world but I I've always had that
intuition that there was a relationship
between the two I mean
yeah I don't know it's it's speculation
on my part but uh yeah well it's a good
speculation though and and I think I
think John has a similar argument
actually about the plague too and and
um but it has something to do with it I
mean it's it's such a that's a it's an
archetypal Motif for a reason right it's
like that that somehow
that somehow there's a certain we have
to die to the possibility of being
renewed into a new form of life and form
of seeing and that I think something
something and I've had my own personal
version of that and it sounds like
you've had your personal version of that
too
meanwhile the sort of the Gathering that
happens on an individual level is
somehow participating in a gathering
that is of a greater order of magnitude
and that when those things become
synchronous something very numinous and
uncanny starts to happen right that like
aporia
begins to
yield the possibility of light
trading it from the outside but that's
like that's a pain it's like we it's
easy to talk about those things in
romantic terms but like
phenomenologically
and existentially the experience is
anything but romantic I think it yeah
the labor pains to your point it feels
remarkably painful it feels like you're
being
squeezed through something very tight
and very dark yeah but it's also there
is attendant to the experience and it
and and it's not I don't think it's the
whole thing I don't think the the game
let's say the play isn't over like the
the process isn't over I think that it
scales and so in some ways that I think
what we're seeing happening is still
seeds it's still seeds it's still like
because
let's say the the old world is still
playing out like the The Madness of the
old world is still playing out and a lot
of even what we're
let's say what we're doing is feeding on
the residues of that old world like
we're still we're still feeding off that
stuff it's still we still need it in
order to kind of even to get the message
across like we're using
yeah the techniques we're using are part
of are part of the issue let's say so so
I mean it's kind of interesting because
we talk about you know the idea of
embodied experience and community and
and the idea of connecting you know is
let's say John has his his practices and
I'm saying people go to church but we're
still doing this online we're still on
YouTube we're still on social media and
so there it's it really is I think
that's part of the feeling of the being
ripped apart to a certain extent is that
it's like we're on a bridge we're kind
of moving from one world to the other
we're not sure how to integrate the old
world because in some ways you do have
to integrate it
um and so we don't not sure how to
integrate it into this new thing
um anyway so so yeah so I think that
probably is part of why it feels so
stretching yeah yeah it does and covid
had something to do with amplifying and
accelerating it I think because
I got this sense and I think a lot of
people did consciously or not that
it was I think for many of us the first
time of becoming aware that we're being
lived out
by to use an Autumn quote by powers that
we don't quite understand and that
we don't we can't get a perspective on
that we can't exactly get a perspective
on what it is that's happening we're
participating in something that has a
presence within and as a presence
without and we're being forced to reckon
with ourselves in a really fundamental
way because the ontology of the world is
suddenly shifting from under us and that
was I mean I it it makes so much sense
to me when I think of that event as a
properly symbolic event right that
whatever the virulence whatever the
whatever the the biological virulence
was the symbolic virulence was
ultimately the far more potent and
powerful thing and what it shows is that
these patterns that we take completely
for granted have a trajectory that is
not entirely known to us
and that they're bearing us out to
something that isn't quite clear but
that our response to it and our way of
integrating it has something to do with
bearing ourselves out through it it's an
incredibly complex thing yeah well I
think that for sure
for sure covet exposed things is maybe
the at least that's the way that I see
it it exposed patterns that were already
there
and so it kind of exposed the isolation
and the loneliness and and it exposed
also the
Reddit exposed the system in the sense
that the the the system how strong the
system is like how powerful the the
political system is and how powerful the
technological system is
and that it made it made it made it
possible for people to be isolated even
more because I I kept
all through covet I kept thinking like
if coveted happened 200 years ago we we
probably wouldn't have talked about it
like people would have died and it would
have been sad and we would have buried
people and and there would have been
like a sense in which there's something
difficult happening but I mean it would
have gripped the entire world and forced
us into our homes for two years because
that was only possible because the
system was so strong and like you know
it revealed the system to us like okay
this is the world we actually live in
you know so now know what that is and it
also revealed this this kind of
loneliness or capacity for autonomy you
know that that that also is the
loneliness like those two things go
together like we can live without
contact with others for a very long time
and we'll be fine physically like we
will we will live and we will we could
even Thrive economically some people
thrive quite well during covet in terms
of in terms of financially but but um so
it's like okay so if we're not
deliberate about our communities if
we're not deliberate about how we're
together
it's not going to happen on its own
because the the situation let's say the
needs of the ancient world
the needs of the ancient world force
people to be together there was no other
way you had to be together because if
you didn't you would just die but now
we've we've set up a world where we
don't but we have we need to so how how
do we do it so it's like it has
something about the the consciousness of
the patterns even in terms of symbolism
for example uh which I think comes with
the problem of the
the problem of a world that isn't
integrated naturally
and so the fact that the symbolic world
isn't integrated naturally like it would
in a you know in a tribe in the in the
middle of the Amazon where they don't
have a choice they have to live under
these trees they have to make fire they
have to you know do these things that
are so you know let's say symbolically
rich and symbolically uh
integrated that they they probably don't
have to think about it it just it just
happens naturally but now we live in in
the in the technical world it's so
strong
that it's revealing the patterns to us
because we've because we we suffer but
we like okay we have to understand how
this works and I think the same with
Community it's like okay so we have to
be deliberate about Community because we
don't have to have community so now what
do we do if we don't if not deliberate
about it then we then we'll die you know
morally like it will die spiritually
maybe not physically but right so if I'm
getting you right it's like our our
whatever is inhibiting our capacity to
participate in these patterns these
patterns that are more perennial the
fact that we're speak we've become so
atomized and coveted in some sense
exposed and maybe even accelerated that
sense of atomization right of being
forced back on our Moorings
independently into solitude
and having to reckon with the POs with
the anxiety I think it is anxiety of
personal responsibility that being so
sort of maximally disintegrated draws
attention to the need for integration
itself
because it's like so there's a kind of
distension going on and I want but that
see that that's so interesting because
it actually makes me wonder whether
there's necessity in that as part of the
pattern itself
just as there may be necessity in the
particular kind of suffering that a
person has to undergo by being so
divided against himself yeah so
disintegrated that having to become many
is requisite for having to be
for for the movement into right the
logos the Gathering back into Unity
again
so I wonder in the same way maybe on a
different scale whether this sort of
this
this
this
fracturing yeah it is part of the
pattern of that movement itself and that
participating in that movement requires
us to take seriously the responsibility
that was forced on us as a consequence
of that Solitude and the anxiety that
comes with it I know I mean I know that
happened to me I know what happened I
mean virtually to everyone I knew like
on a very deep and personal level we
were all forced to sort of live with the
sum of decisions we made or failed to
make
right and and there's an incredible
Despair and guilt
at least I felt it that came with that
but then it was precisely by turning
into that guilt turning into that
despair
that the possibility of gathering back
up again
became actually available and
um and I don't know exactly what to to
do with that or how to generalize it but
I have some sense that that existential
scale of having to re-gather in the face
of that distension has something to do
with the pattern that's happening yeah
chaotically maybe right now but on a
greater scale so I I think I think
you're you're really on to something you
know there's a there's there are a few
tropes let's say in in Christian
theology if you read some of the church
fathers they they'll say something like
you know when Adam fell
the human nature was splintered into
many in many persons many individuals
and that in some ways that was something
that was inevitable with the fall but
then ultimately was going to be
transformed into a regathering that you
mentioned and so you that might sound
abstract to some people but if you think
about
The Way Saint Paul talks about Sin for
example is super interesting
you know when you sin let's say you you
give in to some thing like you lie or
whatever you give in to some passion or
some desire uh that you know is kind of
bringing you astray or ripping you apart
there's something weird that happens
every time is that you actually have an
opportunity yes and then you you it's
like a little moment of being awake
actually sinning is a weird is a weird
moment of waking up because you do
something it's like you know you're
talking and I will send you lie I know
you brag about something and you say
something is not true and you're like
there if you if you're at least somewhat
like still you know unless you're
completely lost but if you're if you're
still somewhat have a little bit of
sense to yourself you'll have an eternal
moment where you're like why did I say
that like what why did I do that
um and that's and that's an opportunity
and so the fall is always an opportunity
to to kind of wake up again and I think
that that's probably something in
general to say if we make that bigger in
terms of you know watching certain
patterns in society can kind of you know
fragment us and atomize us the way you
said then that becomes an opportunity
to to to do something
to do something so it's like it's also
it's almost like the
the problem of Consciousness in some
ways it's almost like you know the um
right it's like the the
self-consciousness of the Fall leads to
this breakdown but then that can be
recuperated into a higher state yes
where it's not innocence right anymore
You're Not Innocent you're you actually
have gone through and now you're
reintegrating in a higher manner
that's beautiful yeah well said well
said well that I that I think that's in
some ways that's um Kierkegaard talks
about that and I think his entire
concept of anxiety like the sort of this
dizziness the vertigo of freedom of
waking up into the consciousness of sin
not as simply as a precondition but as
an infinite possibility that extends out
in front of you and so it's like you're
perched on this precipice and you're
swaying and this sort of dizzying sense
the dizzying possibility of being able
to sin again is something that can only
be resolved by having to shift the
orientation of your attention right
um
from something egocentric to something
that ultimately that grounds you out
and that's an incredibly difficult move
to make because then
here's a question for you because one of
the things I find really interesting is
that
they're sort of
one of the ways in which I think the
socratic platonic tradition interacts
with the Christian tradition in a very
interesting way and in some sense needs
help from it is that
when we have that Socratic Insight of
waking up and getting a moment of
Lucidity where we we catch ourselves in
the act of the sin and we wake up from
it and we
we may wake up from it and have an
Insight in such a way
that we can
reform the relationship we have with
whatever is dynamically attracting us in
our attention
but I think one of the difficulties is
that that coming into Consciousness that
moment of waking up that Socratic kind
of
um light bulb
there's an attendant guilt that
immediately attaches itself to that
right so you were saying before it's
like
when when I come into a new form of life
a new way of seeing a new kind of
relationship with reality it's such that
whatever came before is now Unthinkable
to me right I can't imagine how such a
thing could ever have been tenable but I
think one of the problems is that then
there is a second order
sin
which is that
I'm now despairing over the fact of
having sinned I'm not despairing over
the fact of having been guilty yeah I
know that somehow the Brokenness of the
world is a consequence of the way that I
framed my relationship to it and there's
something that's irrevocably lost
as a consequence of my having failed to
be myself by being in right relation
with what's most real and then that
second order despair that that sin that
guilt over the sin itself
becomes something tremendously
inhibitive because then it's almost as
though in a kind of weird
um sort of perverted platonic problem
it's like the sin becomes the thing
about reality that is most real
and
and that's like that's a real problem
and I think that's one of the ways in
which the sort of the socratic tradition
kind of comes to a point and it can't go
any further yeah because the socratic
tradition can can induce the
consciousness of sin it can wake you up
it can reorient your attention by
forcing an Emporia on you but it doesn't
necessarily have an answer to the
largest of guilt that you inherit
because of waking up
and I think that's why like Kierkegaard
talks about you know Christ as being
both the pattern and also the Redeemer
and that somehow you need both
because it's the Redeemer that allows
for the relief of the guilt such that
you can actually refocus and fashion
your attention again but that attendance
like after covet I think that's part
part of what happened a bunch of people
woke up
but they also found themselves with this
debt of guilt of having broken
themselves all that time that can't
easily be erased anyway I I I I go on
and on but I'm just I'm curious to know
what you make of that problem and and
because it strikes me as something that
you've probably reckoned with yeah I
know I think you're right and I think
like you said the image of Christ
you know as both the shepherd the
Redeemer all this image but also the
judge at the same time and I think that
that you could understand the logos
as having two hands right we we talk I
talked about I talked about that when we
were also in uh in thunder today right
the idea of the of a hand which draws
and a hand which pushes away and um you
know because the logos calls you right
it's like it's the point of light that's
attracting you it's the it's the reason
why you're doing things it's that and
then when you when you when you sin you
feel the logos as a
as a judge because then the distance
between you and the logos now is
appearing it's like it's like this thing
is calling me forward and now I do
something which is not in line with you
know it's it's it's a it's missing the
mark of where I'm going and so now it
exposes the distance between me and the
and the uh and the logos
um but I think that that's why you kind
of need both of those
it's in balance at the same time because
if you you know you do need that wake up
moment but then you also need to feel
the call and I think that's also why
that's why you know love it ends up
being the main motor for the whole thing
you know this this that that there's
love love coming from the logo from
above right there's love coming from
Heaven that that that is drawing you up
and Grace is maybe also uh uh the way
the Christian way to explain that you
know it's like in some ways
you are dependent on on the logos more
than
it's not the opposite it's like it's
it's actually the source of your life
and so it's it's
the very fact that you can see it comes
from it like it it draws you into it so
it's so so that I think that first move
right where it's not just
it's not just that I see this you know I
see God and now it's like okay well now
roll my sleeves up and uh you know and
now suffer because it's like I'm so I'm
so far I have to go up the mountain I
have to you know the kind of this kind
of Sisyphus idea where it's like all
right now roll the hill and roll the
ball up the the hill but but I think
that if you I think when we understand
the logos properly
there's a there's actually something up
on the top of that Hill like
it's there's something calling you
there's something drawing you into it
so it makes the weight light you know
it's like that that's what Christ says
it's like my my yoke is is light you
know it because it because it's
because it's actually moving towards
more reality and so you you kind of are
called by it that's right that's right
and then I think the question becomes
what does it take for the individual
to train his ear to condition the
receptivity
to that call
and maybe that's where kind of the that
that
maybe that's the really properly
speaking the existential role of the
suffering which is that what it does is
it because it it exhausts the inward
resourcefulness of your ego
it kind of leaves you with no choice
right it makes you serious you're sort
of so rent apart you're so Riven that it
sort of sensitizes you it disposes a
kind of vulnerability that opens you to
the possibility of being called forth by
something outside of you
and I mean right because there's this
there's this idea right right through
the tradition of
that you have to somehow sensitize
yourself to the possibility of God's
love yeah and it sounds so easy but it
really really isn't especially when your
own guilt becomes the measure of
everything that's real about you it
becomes almost defiant and demaniacal in
that sense like you the what you're
we're ontological priorities actually
favor the sin
um because it for like these deep
platonic reasons it just well this seems
to be more real than any possibility of
goodness that could exceed it I can't
imagine such a thing yeah I don't know
in the in the platonic in the platonic
systems if people have also
developed the notion of of this fractal
a fractal way of dealing with this which
is in the in the Bible or at least what
Christ's way presents it or you know
when you see it in the uh Our Father
which is you know forgive us our sins as
we forgive those who sinned against us
and so this idea of practicing
Grace or practicing compassion is also a
way to kind of enter into that past if
you can't you can't see the way in which
Grace can pull you up but then you can
actually do that to others yes and when
you do it to others you enter into the
pattern and I think that it makes it
probably possible for kind of Grace to
act on you because it's like I'm seeing
you know it's like I I'm letting
something go right someone did something
against me I'm letting it go I'm
exercising Grace and so you know all of
a sudden it becomes a possibility it
becomes transitive it becomes transitive
that's right that's beautiful right so
that by participating on on in one
aspect of the pattern
right you you actually yeah it's it's
like you
it's like you invoke a belief in the
capacity in in being able to take on the
opposite aspect to the one that's
actually acting out right and people
people have to be careful they don't
it's not like uh it's not like uh it's
like a transaction right it's not like
okay well I'm gonna I'm gonna do this
for others so then I get from that it's
rather just embodying something and by
embodying it then you party you are
necessarily participating it and it's by
being related to it I think yeah there
you go it's like you enter whatever side
of the relation you happen to be on
right if it's analogized as it right
because it's the same ultimately a
fractal of the same pattern you're
ultimately relieving yourself in the
pattern in such a way that you're
assuming a role within it but that also
means that the part in the pattern that
you play plays host to the whole of the
pattern which is what makes it by
definition symbolic right when the
presence is the whole
and so it's it's almost as though
because you're embodying somehow the
whole of the pattern and the part that
you play Within it
there's they're kind of inculcates a
belief and not a belief in the
prepositional sense but like a belief
and an enacted a sensitization to that
pattern that allows you to turn in in in
the opposite direction and see it on a
different scale and and there's and I
think there's also like a there's also
the reverse to that and no but I think
it's not like I said it's not a system
we have to be careful because we can
always find counter examples of of this
but I I have noticed for example that
let's say let's say people who are
capable of engaging in uh
let's say in generosity and kind of and
kind of giving themselves and a capacity
to let's say also
try to find the good in others you know
in their first response ultimately end
up often being also surrounded by that
that is that it actually grows and they
do end up attracting people that have
that goodness and so keep often people
end up living in a world that's more
full of goodness and the opposite is
true as well people who who who let's
say act that say dishonestly towards the
people around them at some point start
to also attract that
from the people that interact with them
and so they end up in a world of
mistrust you know both the way they act
but also what they receive from the
world and so there's actually like a so
people can actually inhabit like you
really can have a different worlds
just by the way they act and the what
they see as how would they prioritize
and how they act not just in what they
do but when what they receive I don't I
can't explain it scientifically but it's
definitely something I know but that
I've noticed yeah I'm with you I'm with
you I notice it too I think I think once
you once you have eyes on it like once I
mean that's like what we were talking
about before once you begin
once you begin to to pick up these
patterns
they're pretty hard to mistake and I
think that's what I mean that's why
people are so like that I think that's
why in part people are so responsive to
the work that you do is because
once they take this kind of once they
take the idea of these sort of Mythic
structures and they start to put them
like a stencil to drop them down into
their own ways of living
it's amazing the way that they
synchronize and and then what's so
fascinating about that is that becoming
conscious of the way that they're
synchronizing
invites a participation in them that is
more credulous and more faithful because
suddenly I don't need convincing
of the fruitfulness of doing this
it's just it's obvious right and it's
obvious on a level that is embodied
right it's very visceral and you've gone
into it by virtue of having noticed it
in such a way that I realize I'm already
in a relationship to It For Better or
For Worse or maybe for both at once
no I I can see it in the sense that
sometimes I imagine myself you know like
as a as a Peds let's say a Russian
peasant in the 19th century and and how
let's say the patterns in which people
were living were so naive they were true
a lot of them were true and were real
but they were very innocent and so in
some ways they were in very much in
danger and so when you know when the
material is kind of secularist narrative
comes in people get crushed you know and
and I saw that even when I was young I
would see people you know people with a
kind of naive faith
um
a very confident but naive naive faith
and then you know the they would go to
university and then they would just get
crushed and they would they would go to
their first philosophy class and they
would just be completely demolished
because they had never heard anything
like this and never heard any of these
arguments and never thought about any of
these things and they would end their
University you know in Quebec we we had
the thing called sejet which is like and
they had philosophy classes in sejap and
I think those philosophy classes were
even just designed
to like
slash the Catholicism out of all the
quebecers that went through that in the
60s in the in the 70s when they were
installed and it worked like it totally
worked because people came in these
naive little church Growers and then
were completely destroyed but what's
interesting so now we go through this
Loop and now we come to let's say this
this movement this kind of this more
this symbolic understanding people kind
of re-understanding the role of
perception of attention and how it
shapes our narratives how it shapes the
way the reality manifests itself
and once people have gone through that
that let's say that training
what are you gonna how are you gonna
take that away from them like like how
are you how are those site how are those
philosophy professors going to take that
away from them I don't think it's
possible anymore like I I always say
it's like I don't there's nothing you
could tell me I don't I mean maybe I
don't know I don't I feel like I've
heard it all like I feel like there's
what is it that you're going to tell me
that you're gonna convince me no back
into that old world I don't see it
happening I don't see it happening
either I think it's I mean it's a big
statement to say it's impossible but it
feels impossible it feels impossible
because what you're re-introduced what
we're talking about is the
reintroduction of a kind of contact
epistemology
and by definition like in virtue of its
very nature
it can't be Unwound by any kind of
propositional response and man it's at
that level that all of this these
institutions and these sort of these
these these sort of trenchant
mentalities are operating right I mean
that's one of the reasons why they're so
viscerally unsatisfying after a period
of time because it's like I mean
that that's that dissatisfaction
Socratic dissatisfaction with the
proposition
is precisely what's What's
um
what's divesting us from those
institutions in the first place and so
when we make contact with something
that is real in virtue of the contact
itself I don't think there's any amount
of debate that can necessarily uproot it
I don't know I mean it depends I guess
it just it's a matter I mean I'm talking
in yeah but you get I mean there'll be
there'll be debates about the details
there'll be debates about about the
formulations there'll be all these
debates will happen but the fundamental
shift that that that that that that
happens you can't you won't I don't
think it'll be very difficult to debate
that because
that's it right that's it and when you
because when you take it on especially
when you take it on in the inward Mythos
of your psyche when you start to realize
that your very way of thinking is
actually populated with these patterns
and you start to trace them out in the
most personal of ways
that can't but induce a kind of
faithfulness an attention toward the
relationship that is being organized by
all of these things I think that's why
like you know
had that famous interview at the end of
his life when someone said you know do
you believe in God you sort of he goes
like I know
like I don't need to believe yeah you
know what I mean like I I'm
the way I my my contact with reality is
such that these kinds of questions the
way that they're framed are kind of
irrelevant now not enough not in a not
in a uh you know not in a sanctimonious
way but just yes somehow somehow the way
the relationship that I have with the
world has exceeded the scope in which
these kinds of questions are relevant
anymore and I think there's a kind of
anti I think certain people when they go
to university I mean even at the very
beginning of their careers when they're
students
there's almost something anticipatory
about that that you know it's like I
mean I found this I found I mean I
started taking philosophy as an
undergraduate and I just I I went into
it thinking that I loved it and that it
was going to be so deeply satisfying and
within a couple of sessions I
I was like I
I had enough right because because it
was it had nothing to do with the
embodiment of wisdom it had nothing to
do with personal orientation they had no
existential import right and I think
that because of that
because of that I think it's capacity to
to put sink its hooks into people I
think is is pretty dulled you know
pretty dulled maybe necessarily so
and so how do you see that in your own
on your own path let's say how are you
integrating these changes in your own
yeah that's a good question I think I
think I'm at a point now like I
struggled with that I've struggled with
that for a long time because
because I had this sort of
um
I had this this sort of Eros for
philosophy That Couldn't
quite consummate itself within the
scholarly context
which is not not to say there's nothing
there's that context isn't valuable on
its own terms it definitely is I just
found that I couldn't somehow the
relationship you know it's sort of like
when you you meet someone and you look
them you I'd really like to but like
we're going to be friends and then you
and you try and it's just the friendship
just doesn't it just doesn't happen it
just doesn't Bloom and you want it
that's we're going to be friends but you
can't force friendship right
or any kind of relationship so the
relationship just didn't catch the fire
just didn't catch
and so I was yeah I was left pretty um
I was left
I was left dizzy and I was left
wandering and um I mean meeting John was
I think pivotal for me in that I
discovered that the thing that I thought
philosophy was actually was there was a
reality to it now I found a
corresponding referent to it right
someone who did that which I thought it
always was
and um and you know that before and
after effect that we were talking about
before of coming into understanding
things the organization of things in a
different way happened to me as a
consequence of that relationship and
still does
but how to translate that love and that
point of contact into something
um more concrete that's still that
question I think is still very difficult
to be honest that's one of the things
that I really I was going to say this
like
one I I
I'm very
um
I'm I'm quite inspired by the work that
you do for that reason because I think
that you have found a way
a very ancient way
um of
I mean I took semiotics right that was
actually the program my Prime main
program of study was in semiotics and I
got bored with that too because it was
pretty much all French structuralism and
post-structuralism
and you know
enough said and
but it's interesting to me that what
you're doing is you're sort of you're
you're actually
you're kind of a working semiotician in
some sense right you're taking it upon
yourself to kind of transliterate the
structures that are implicit in things
into their their symbolic language and
to translate it into a language that
makes it intelligible for people and you
found a way to do that
without needing to root it in the
overtly academic Enterprise or the
overly scholarly Enterprise
and that for me is a that's a very
significant thing like that's a very
rare thing and I find that very elusive
so
um anyway this is all to say it's it's I
think it's an unfolding story I think
I'm getting closer I think I'm getting
it took a long it took a long time of
it's been gestating for a while but I
think
I think in consonance with everything
that we're talking about of this sort of
this this this sense of synchronization
that's happening that things are
gathering together I feel that also on a
personal scale that
um that makes the possibility they're
obviously much more viable now than it
has ever seemed before
so um I know are you are you are
attached to Academia are you are you
involved I don't know what you're no
you're not at all so you're not I
thought you were involved in University
of Toronto with John Like That You Were
Somehow involved no okay no no I'm not
I'm not
um no I mean I was always it was always
uh
it was sort of a foregone conclusion to
me that I would take that route
but I just I just didn't I sort of I
finished my first degree and I was I
didn't I didn't have a concrete sense of
how I fit in to that world like there
were sort of some logistical issues some
administrative issues like I was so
eclectic
in my studies that I didn't really focus
and specialize in such a way that made
possible a particular course or a
particular path I did a lot of wandering
and
um and I mean one of the reasons that I
took to John and why we took to each
other is because I certain he found a
home in that eclecticism and as a way of
integrating it together that spoke to me
and resonated with me
um but when you translate that into you
know the bodies of universities and how
to fit into that body and be part of
that body and participate in it
to use your your use of body
um that that was much more of a
difficult question so I deferred I
deferred the question I deferred it I
deferred it and I deferred it and I
deferred it and I just kept deferring it
sort of like a a long-term extended
deferral of the question of what to do
about that yeah that's still an open
question but um
but yeah I'm I'm starting to gather that
together again I think the next couple
of years are going to be are going to be
pivotal but um but I yeah but I needed a
long period I think to figure out like
there was some some kind of weird
essentialism in my mind about taking
that route because it's the only way
it's because it's the only proper into
which this kind of work in the world
that in the way that the world is kind
of configured right now I just sort of
I just sort of had a narrative sort of
yeah a narrative that that's where it
would have to be and it took a while
embarrassingly a long time really
to kind of realize that that narrative
was not as essential as I had always
believed it to be yeah and um so I mean
that's one of the reasons I I I I
appreciate your work and I appreciate
other folks who have
who have decided no I'm going to do this
work I'm going to take this Enterprise
but I don't need any of that structure
in order to make it real yeah I don't
need to be like I don't need to be a
scholar to be a philosopher I don't need
to like this scaffolding is important
and valuable but it's not it's not
necessary in the sense that I think I
always believed it was and it's hard to
do away with a belief like that right
because a belief like that is not just a
propositional belief it's a premise of
the world it's a premise of the way the
world functions and so to get to dig
down and uproot a belief like that
the entire vision of the world needs to
change first yeah right yeah it's it's
funny because I think I'm not sure what
year was I think it was 2014. 2014 maybe
2013 2014 I'm not sure exactly but I I
was trying to kind of make it as an icon
Carver
and uh and I I was contacted by the head
of of the Yale Divinity School I guess
and they wanted people to apply to their
this Fellowship they had which was like
an art fellowship or something and I
applied to the fellowship and I wrote my
proposition of what it is that I wanted
to do
um
and then I didn't get in you know
obviously but
it was funny because when I think about
that proposition now
it's pretty much what I'm doing now it's
like just everything that I'm doing now
and and I understand why they didn't
accept it because it was like I'm
supposed to be an icon cover but then
I'm talking about
symbolism and I'm talking about like
understanding iconography as like
symbolic pattern for reality and like
I'd like to talk about that and like to
interpret stories and I'd like to
continue my carving at the same time and
and it's just hilarious uh that at least
in my case it feels like somehow that
formulation was like a weird seed that I
was kind of planting somewhere you know
throwing out into the world and then
then it happened without the academy and
probably better
I think in my case it's because I'd have
the freedom to to not
follow the structures like it's it's
pretty heavy I find like that what what
Academia asks of you to be able to say
something is quite heavy in terms of
what it what it requires you know the
whole model of citation and the whole
model of of also fitting it into these
very very precise research projects that
are becoming more and more precise you
know as time goes on because it's like
you have to kind of find your little
niche
um and that's why it's astounding that
that someone like John is able to even
do what he does like that that he's able
to find but I think he suffered also
he's a rare bird I mean yeah
and he has suffered for it for sure yeah
he hasn't been able to find that what do
they call it the the the the right the
path in the University too to to to you
know it took a long time for him to be
able to find his place
um
yeah
so so but it is but it's also
frightening to do it outside of the
academy because you have that problem
like I have that problem I find it funny
I love it actually I kind of I kind of
have a perverse pleasure when someone
tries to introduce me it's always it's
always
because it's funny I have the same
problem I have the same problem I want
laboring under a particular occupational
identity
you you end up you're in this weird
intercategorical space it's like what am
I I don't know I'm I'm my I'm me but
what is that I and I know I can I've
noticed that and I've noticed your sort
of ironic smirk every time um someone
introduces you in a way that's a fire
you somehow became a monk in Thunder Bay
um oh yeah yeah or like I mean I love it
even Jordan always as I said he's a
Russian he's a Russian French Canadian
Russian Orthodox icon Carver and I'm
just like that's hilarious you know you
need to add a few more things to that to
make it even more confusing
it's obviously that's it's like the fact
that people even say that I'm an icon
cover now is just hilarious because it's
obviously not true anymore I mean it's
very but maybe people are detecting that
like I mean if we think about it in
proper symbolic terms icon carving is in
some sense what you are doing in your
video right you are rendering a moving
image of a symbolic pattern such that
people can face it face to face and
apprehend it and so in some sense if we
if we just oh yeah that's interesting
right if we extend the reference I
actually think that the title as
presented is pretty apt it just requires
a little bit of imagination
um but you know being a tapas in the way
that you are I think is actually quite
helpful because I think it allows you to
straddle like it allows you a certain
amount of Mobility at a time when that
kind of being able to migrate across
these worlds and domains is part of the
project of transliterating their
respective grammars and the way that
you're actually doing so it's like
one like that's what I want that's what
I find so interesting about what you're
doing is that somehow the presentation
of your title and the nature of the work
are somehow there's a
there's a continuity there of some kind
that is I think important if I can be so
no that's it I never it's funny that
when you said it I never thought about
that but uh but I'll I'll have to even
take more joy in the in the icon cover
designation from now on because yeah
yeah
yeah it's happening in many levels you
know something like that yeah totally I
I truly think so I truly think so and um
and maybe that's one of the things that
uh I don't know how how
conscious uh Jordan Peterson is when he
when he sort of equivocates on your
title but maybe there's some he has some
sense of that too I don't know maybe
that's funny I don't know I don't know
and so what do you what do you or what
are you working on now like what what
are the things that are drawing your
attention yeah so I mean I'm working on
a few different projects with John I'm
uh I've come on as another author his
Awakening from the meaning crisis
lecture series is being turned into a
book yeah
um so I'm on that project that's like
taking a big chunk of my time right now
is basically I'm I've come on as another
author to basically just you know
to work on that and to because it's not
right they're very a lecture Series in a
book or just they're very very different
beasts and they require a different they
you know a different set of tools and so
so that's what I'm working on right now
um we're also doing this Dia logos
project in many dirt there's going to be
a monograph I think we're going to work
on
um but there's also this course that
we're we've pulled together with guy
sangstock and it's it's still I would
say we've done about four
iterations of it now and it's going very
well and it's still very tentative we're
trying to be cautious about you know
because this is I mean it's very old but
it's also very new at the same time
and so we're really just trying to play
with different iterations of it
formulating this method in different
ways kind of trying it out it's a very I
think it's kind of a playful process
right now of just seeing like what
happens what happens when we do this
what happens when We Gather a bunch of
people together to undertake this
practice instead of circling like it
would be a class on circling it's
circling the DNA of circling is in it
for sure but it's really is a kind of
way of
simulating and recreating the socratic
dialogue I have to be careful when I use
these terms which is yeah because
Socratic like there's there are so many
codified versions of Socratic dialogue
now and they have their trademarks and
whatnot okay really yeah yeah I mean
when I think of it I just think of
Plato's dialogues I don't think in that
codified sense
but the idea is of taking a virtue
putting it at the center of a
dialectical process
um and there's a little bit of circling
technique in there
um as well and basically taking that a
dialectical structure and trying to
build it on itself so that it actually
turns into Dia logos right so that the
process of needing and molding and
um and co-creating a definition of
virtue becomes a way of developing a
relationship with that virtue right so
the proposition of The Virtue right the
proposed definition is is kind of it has
no um it has no propositional value per
se all it really is is a kind of
is
um
is is basically a Log on the Fire to
kind of get
to to get it going and um
anyway so so we're we're sort of playing
around with this
um and um and so far it's going very
well so far so far it actually seems to
be reliably producing
I'm always very I'm always very careful
about this because there's something
about the spontaneous nature of dialogos
when it happens this idea that there's a
kind of animesis at work right that
somehow the way that we're relating to
each other is triangulating to a way of
of
communing with the patterns that are
that and sort of that that Gathering
Together of different aspects of
something whether it be a person or a
virtue is something that when done
between two people with their attention
fixed in the middle and fixed on the
unfolding of that relationship has
something to do with opening to The
Gathering of that pattern and allowing
something to shake shape in recollection
such that we seem to discover something
and to create it at the same time
and that's so really I think what Dia
logos is properly speaking is it's a way
of generating a symbolic process of
drawing forth logos and and tracing it
out and following it and that's I mean
speaking that way is tricky because it
sounds awfully highfalutin but it's
really just a way of using
dialogue and the knowing of one another
to
to create
a way of
a way of knowing between ourselves a way
of of of of
conducting something yeah and if let's
say realizing
that the that the whole is more than the
the parts just having that experience in
with someone exactly exactly using the
part whether but really the part of a
virtue or one aspect of a person to host
and presence the movement from the part
to the whole right a bonocentric
movement right a movement toward the
good yeah and that movement has
something to do with being able to take
that one aspect or one part
and use it as a host
to as a relationship with whatever is
behind it and Beyond it and
um and and so you kind of move from the
propositional domain into something far
more visceral far more participatory and
far more spontaneous than a kind of
formal the formal structure of the
dialectic is really just like I said
it's sort of the logs on the fire you
know it's a means to an end really
um so anyway so that that project is
kind of ongoing and I don't know yet
what that will become in some ways very
much like any given dialogues it kind of
it is gathering kind of of its own
accord
and um and each time it seems to get a
little tighter each time we refine it a
little more
and um and its future is open I think we
want to be cautious about it you know
but at the same time there seems to be
great promise in it so anyway so those
are the sort of the things I'm doing
with John and and I've got some some
writing projects of my own that uh are
always deferred but that at some point I
need to get to so we'll see it's an
exciting time though you know there's
quite a lot happening it's hard to keep
together at once which is a problem I'm
sure you have too
yeah I just I'm also I have a let's say
because I also have this more artistic
aspect I tend to have to just I'm trying
to decide now what
because I let's say I have the
possibility of maybe writing a book that
would be more like a presentation of the
symbolic world you know just like a
non-fiction book but then I also really
want to write fairy tales and so I it's
so the fairy tales are winning I'm sorry
for anybody you know who who might have
wanted me to do the other one fairy
tales are definitely winning and I'm way
more excited about writing fairy tales
than I am about
the other stuff so so that's been taking
up that's actually kind of taking up my
Horizon right now
which is I I have this intuition what
what I called it apocalyptic
storytelling it sounds a little weird
but it's about there's something that
hap it's about it's a little bit about
taking the postmodernism that has just
happened and let's say trying to
reconsolidate it into something which
offers a higher Insight so one of the
aspects of postmodern storytelling is
something like collage it's like there's
a collage aspect to postmodern
storytelling and it finds itself you
know a simple example that is like the
Marvel Universe right so you have all
these independent characters that that
coexist and then people will paste them
together to create more interesting
attention and though their qualities
will be brought we kind of smashed
together to kind of to to create these
these crossovers people call them right
so so that's actually really a kind of
of a post-modern type of of Storytelling
um and then people started doing it in
different ways you they did it with
fairy tales quite a bit so you have
things like Shrek into the woods uh you
had something called fables this whole
comic book series where they took all
these comments they took all these fairy
tale characters and they would throw
them to together into a story and a
story that was usually quite dark and
cynical uh and would kind of expose the
underlying supposedly power structure
than political patterns that the fairy
tales are made of
um and it was it's actually quite a
successful form of Storytelling because
it's it can be it can give you those
inside moments even though they're
rather dark insights they can give you
insights about that so what I want to do
is to turn that back to flip it back
where like I'm going to actually take
all these characters fairy tale
characters also kind of smash them
together but use one to reveal more
insight about what the other is instead
of but Insight not in in terms of just
political power and and raw that kind of
raw stuff that's at the bottom but
rather a more a higher insight about how
reality works and so it's like you know
can I use
and and then can I use let's say can I
use Snow White to help you understand
with the fall of Adam and Eve is without
mentioning the fall of Adam and Eve like
without saying anything about the Bible
but but just saying well it's like
there's that Apple there's that
Temptation there's that like what is it
what is it is there a relationship
between the two so I've been doing that
with some I'm not writing the third one
uh and and it's been so exciting for me
because it's like the stories for
example like I'm writing Jack and the
Beanstalk right now and and it's like
I've loved that story since I was a kid
but there has been aspects about that
that have been bothering me since I was
a kid like why is he the main character
Jack is a thief basically he's a
trickster and a thief like what is he
doing and like why is he stealing these
things from the Giants and like what's
going on in that story what the hell's
going on and so I actually feel like I
like I by by writing them I feel like
I've gained massive insights into these
stories and so I'm really excited to to
to kind of bring people along into into
these fairy tales and uh and kind of
surprise them and hope they can have
higher insights about what these stories
are about thanks I'm real that's what
excited me right now it's like if I if I
could that's probably all I would do is
just write these fairy tales oh what a
great project well I love that it seems
to be a project that's kind of saturated
in in a kind of and there's like a
winking irony that I'm hearing about it
because you're sort of you're trying
it's like a project of infiltrating yeah
a cultural myth that has been fractured
by a particular ideological infection
and and working within the fragmentation
to re-gather it and find the hidden
Harmony again yeah but also also it's
like and not doing iteration it's not
something about like an artistic
restoration that I'm hearing that's also
has a higher T loss to it so you can you
think about it like if you think about
like a lot of the fairy tales you know
you can see it like people will say it's
like oh those fairy tales like Sleeping
Beauty you know it's about puberty it's
about sex and it's about like
menstruation it's about all these things
and and then all the conservatives like
no no no no no it's just an innocent
story that's just about like a girl
falling asleep and a prince and I'm like
you know what
yeah it is about that stuff and I'm
gonna show you what it means like I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna dive in and
I'm gonna tell you a story that an adult
will read at an adult level and we'll
see all the insights and a child will
still be able to read at the child level
and completely like it'll be fine for
them like it won't it won't also
scandalize them or or let's say ruin
their childhood but it's like I can tell
the story in a way that a grown-up will
read it and go oh my goodness oh really
okay and it's like because you see that
in things like Shrek where there's all
these dirty jokes and tracks and lots
yeah but it's like I'm gonna say like
I'm not gonna do it just just to like
make you feel like you're a grown-up
with your little dirty uh humor it's
like I want you to understand more about
the Deep aspects of of what these
symbols are about so yes I'm super
excited it's like it's probably the
thing that excites me the most oh that
is exciting well because it also gives
you an opportunity that's like
when when
I kind of had this experience the the
when we were doing the zombies in
Western culture when I was working with
John and Phil on zombies one other thing
I things I found so interesting is that
so many of the
attributions
the Mythic undertones that people
proposed as really the real and I know
you you did a video on that topic too a
little while back that so many of the
explanations that are presented and
proposed as accounting for that myth are
true they're just not comprehensive yeah
they're just not sufficient it's like
well it's a critique of capitalism it's
like well yeah but keep following the
scent right it's like Capital you know
it's like yes consumerism is itself a
symptom of something else that is the
real object of the of the myth right so
it's almost like a lot of these
ideological interpretations of the
moment they'll find an aspect or a
dimension that is true and real it's
just not sufficiently true and
sufficiently real so being able to
being able to kind of weave your way
through some of those things that are
proposed but to follow them a little bit
deeper that what a worthwhile project
that's kind of what I'm hearing a little
bit and what and doing it in story form
like I think that's what's exciting it's
you know I I keep saying that it's like
there could be let's say in terms of the
zombie story like once you realize the
zombie story like there could be ways to
now tell a zombie story that would not
be theoretical there would be no there
would be no explanations in it but that
would just dive back into it with the
Insight we have and tell a deeper more
profound zombie story and maybe even
propose a solution it's one of the
problems with the zombie story is that
there's never a solution no by
definition by definition but maybe there
could be an interesting like solution
that would be taken from within the
mythological frame and not not not
something just dropped in but like
within the very logic of the of the
story that there there could be an
Insight that could be right right some
component that signifies the restoration
of the pattern whose conversion is
actually being played out
yeah I think so I think that that at
least at least for me I think that's
what's it's like it's also because I've
been talking about this stuff for for
now I guess five six years and it's like
now I also have to do it like I you know
it's like I I have to show that it's not
just about interpreting stories we gotta
write better stories but here's the
thing okay so let me ask you this though
because this is fascinating but the kind
of the kind of um the kind of skill it
takes to interpret a story and the kind
of skill it takes to write a story I
think of as very different skills
because when you're when you're
undertaking an analysis a kind of
careful structural analysis of a pattern
of a story as you do so well
you know you're it's there's a there's a
it's a it's a very very conscious very
meticulous very very kind of um
there's a lot of conscious attention
being brought to bear on breaking apart
its components in order to put them back
together again there's a real analytical
frame of mind that you have to be in in
order to do that but when you're
creating something artistically
it seems to me like at least with in my
own experience it seems to me that you
have to yield in order to actually
produce something of artistic Merit you
need to yield the process a certain
amount of that process to the
unconscious like if it's not spontaneous
if it's too over determined by a
conscious analytical process I think it
will fail some of it has to be very
there has to be an unconscious movement
toward the creation of something and how
so how do you like how does that work
for you how does that tension work for
you yeah it's I think at least for me
it's it's just two different spaces
right what is it that it it's completely
Mis applied but I think still I think it
still works so the Christ says that you
know that the right that the left hand
should not know what the right hand is
doing right in some ways there's a sense
in which you
like I always tell people to it like
when people are writing stories I I
always tell them it's like don't think
about symbolism when you're writing a
story it'll kill it like you can't think
about symbolic structures when you're
writing there's you should never do that
no no because then you'll fail them
right you totally fail like you'll fail
in every way like you'll just you'll
overthink it you'll try to fit things in
that don't fit in the in the thrust of
the narrative there's all these things
you'll end up doing
um I think with the way to do it is
it it has to be you have to ruminate
like you ruminate on on the patterns
right and you just kind of let them sit
like almost like almost like you know
they're
fermenting in your in yourself
um and then that becomes the the wine
out of which the story can be told but
it's not now it's not a it's not a
system it's not a structure it's none of
that it's just just it's intuition and
then what you can do the way that I do
it at least myself is that like the
intuition comes for the story then then
it then it's like oh yeah that story
those elements and then once you've put
them down
then you can come back with the symbolic
mind and then you the symbolic mind is
like an editor then you come back and
you're like oh you don't first you have
to be careful with that editor but you
can shift a few things like you can
change a few words and say oh if I tweak
this word then it's actually kind of
more in the direction of what I want but
the the actual elements of the story
come from a more
immediate you know more more immediate
thing right right so it's almost like
you I mean you have so you have all of
this rumination that has taken place
because of all of the deep ways in which
you've been contemplating all of this
over the course of time but then in some
sense there's a kind of divine
forgetfulness that you have to have it's
like I think I think of the way that
really good
um uh performers like really good actors
or musicians kind of describe their
process which is that they State they
are as studious as they can possibly be
for as long as they can possibly be and
when then when the time comes to perform
they do their very best to throw
everything out yeah right and forget
they they they find it in them
to forget everything it is that they
know in order for something a deeper
form of recollection to take place right
it's a kind of a paradox right you need
to have a kind of forgetfulness in order
for the animesis to actually happen and
that's what I'm kind of hearing from you
it's like you you've done all of this
work but then in some sense you have to
take it I'm thinking of your I'm
thinking of your left and right hands
again right that that that the that the
logos that the that the the logos of
judgment that takes has to yield itself
to the Eros of generosity that gives and
that there has to be something a
coordinated withdrawal in order for
something to actually be brought forth
yeah and I think I think you've you've
got it right and
but I do think it is strange like it
you're right that usually
it's rare that you find
usually you have critics and you have
artists right you don't have both at the
same time you know and so it's a strange
thing I don't know like I don't totally
understand it it's possible maybe that
also my art suffers let's say that this
we'll see we'll see when people will
judge them like the story that I write
might suffer for my for my over thinking
but you know at least for now I'm really
excited about them like I'm excited
about writing them so I think if it's
happening I think if it feels like it's
happening with a certain amount of
spontaneous energy then I that to me is
a sure sign that it's that's somehow the
that that has the right bearing right
because you kind of know the difference
right when you're caught in a flow and
something is writing itself through you
right when you have the Sensation that
you're simply the vehicle for something
to produce itself I think that's a
testament to something that's a more
genuine artistic process but when you're
trying to have this sort of overweening
Consciousness that's trying to master
yeah it just doesn't matter so I think a
way to explain it at least is that let's
say it's like if I'm meditating on
writing a story or making an image the
the inside will present itself in this
in story form
right it'll present itself as elements
of the story it won't present itself as
a structure that I'm trying to impose on
the story so it's the same with an image
like I'm trying to figure out an image
then the the inside will present itself
as an element in the image and so I
think that also helps like just that
like to just remain within the the world
I think that helps so
to not to not be in to not be in danger
of trying to just impose this symbolic
structure almost arbitrarily over over a
story and you see it like there you see
Hollywood movies where
you know they take the hero's journey or
whatever and they apply it so
formulately that it's just it's actually
becomes unbearable to watch it's so
broad it's so it looks it lacks the very
specificity that is able to presence a
symbolic pattern right because it's only
with absolute specificity that that can
actually happen
yeah and there's there's a kind of
there's also a kind of messiness you
know because let's say the hero's
journey it never exists purely it
doesn't exist it's like you can you look
at these very complex and and stories
that have all these twists and turns and
and strangeness to them and then you're
like oh you look you look at 10 you know
you look at 50 of them and you're like
oh well here's this sorry here's this
like basic pattern like it's it's real
it's true it's there but you know it
that's not the story like the story has
a greediness to it and has a you know in
the body into it so you can't you can't
just now say well I'm gonna apply this
pattern back onto the world completely
and it just that's what that yields
really no no it has to it has to come it
has to come from within the specific
conditions right it's like it's bottom
up it's not yeah right it has to it has
to emerge as a consequence of your
interaction with the fundamental
conditions that are present it's the the
necessity it's that you need the finite
necessary end of the dichotomy the
infant it end the the possible end
that'll take care of itself it's the
attention to the necessary details that
create the finite enclosure of
circumstance that actually allow for
that to be accessed right which is part
of the beauty of that Paradox I think I
just finished one of my favorite pieces
of of uh of Television I just finished
it's called Better Call Saul and I think
it's a it's an absolutely it's not it's
like a neat it's like an existential
neoplatonic Treatise when it's all said
and done it's just like incredible
mind-boggling piece of symbolic finesse
the likes of which I've never seen
before and you would think and I and I
started to listen to all of these sort
of background details about the creative
process because I thought like who are
these people that produce this like the
amount of meticulousness they must have
and they do from a craftsmanship
perspective but when describing
it's like they seem to somehow follow
the logos such that every turn that the
characters take is absolutely surprising
but absolutely necessary and clear
otherwise it brings me back to this
necessary co-identity between creation
and Discovery inventio right is a word
yeah John likes to use that captures
both at once right the poesis is such
that it um reveals what already was and
in so doing makes it real and the
process the artistic process which is a
dialogical process because it's in a
writer's room which is fascinating right
so it's a dialogical process using a
kind of a dialectic to catch a pattern
between a group of people and then in
that group of people it's almost like a
weird Seance it's like they catch the
pattern of the character from within the
conditions that they've contrived and
yet there is this sort of top-down
pattern that is coming to meet it in the
middle and so I listen to an account of
of the creator of the show describing
the process and someone's asking them
like my god did you guys have this all
plotted out meticulously and he laughed
he said no it's like we were like in the
dark with a lantern and we saw two feet
in front of us
and every step we took we went oh God
look at that right it was like they were
they weren't contriving anything somehow
they found it in them to discover what
was necessary about the next phase of
the story simply by tumbling over the
perspective of the character right I
thought that was incredibly that was
just a a really beautiful to me a
beautiful Testament to exactly this
process that you're describing right
and there's probably like the level to
which this comes is probably to where
this can go is probably very very high
because when you think like when I for
example like when I read the the Comedia
when I read the Dante I have the same I
have that problem I'm like there's no
way this guy could plan this whole thing
out in advance this is not possible like
did you have massive charts like that
would take up entire walls with like
connecting all these verses together and
and making this like giant spider web
that you know is is is Matt it's like I
I can't imagine that that's what it was
and maybe I who knows if he had such a
mind but I think it probably more has
more to do with that capacity to attend
and to and to just be sensitive to to
reality and so like you said it just
kind of came together in almost like a
mystical way yeah uh you know so I mean
I might be wrong I might be but but it's
like when you read the when you read
some think about you like is how can how
can anybody write that it doesn't seem
possible I think well and I think the
thing I mean I I agree with you I think
it's as plausible a way of thinking
about it as any other and I'm inclined
to agree I'm inclined to think no it he
probably sat down maybe I mean I you
know when it came to refining the work
making it probably more of that top down
but
I mean I've had the experience myself
not in comparison to Dante but I've had
that experience myself of sitting down
and writing something and finding that
it was flowing out and then you know
after a couple hours go by it's like I
look at it and I reread it and this
structure comes out I go that like I
didn't intend that that just happened
right or someone else will pick up on it
and I had no knowledge of it whatsoever
and to me I mean it's like if I can
experience that on this very very modest
scale I have no trouble believing that
someone with the artistic Genius of
Dante could sit down and write in such a
way as to recede his own territory to
seed his Consciousness to that Muse to
the to the force of poesis that was
working its way through him and to let
it right because the the structure is
already like I mean it's a priority
right the unconscious structures are
there I mean I take that kind of Union
perspective on it right it's like the
the the
structure's already there it's just
about developing the axis with it in
order to actually seed territory to it
when it's most needful to do so and I
think that's the difficult part is
getting out of your own way as it were
right yeah and then you you can
understand why like you know because you
mentioned the muses you can understand
why it was formulated that way yeah yeah
why in some ways it was
you know it was almost like an invoking
right it's like I'm invoking this
because I it's actually I know that it
doesn't totally come from my will it's
like it can't it has to somehow you know
land in me like somehow and then and
then then obviously you're part of it
like you're part of the creation of it
but you need that vertical
relationship you know yeah oh yeah and
your participation in it I think has
much more to do with allowing it to be
to let the letting it be the
surrendering right there's a kind of
self-sacrifice
I think that is implicit and necessary
in that kind of exercise and then that
participates in the greater pattern of
self-sacrifice that's required in order
to refocus right the that that shift
from being much more egocentric to
putting yourself in service to a pattern
who's unfolding you can participate in
but not be singularly responsible for
then becomes the purpose right so that
little Min in miniature that little
artistic humiliation of the ego the
giving up yourself so that whatever it
needs to come out can
can I think help to maybe
inseminate the faith or the idea that on
a greater scale on a more existential
level that that's something that's
required of us in other ways and the
artistic project I think is a wonderful
a wonderful symbolic container for that
yielding up of
you know what comes before us but what
ultimately comes through us as well
right yeah the Midwifery of it oh yeah
exactly that's a good that's a good way
to Midwifery is a good way to think of
it yeah listen Christopher I think I
think it's probably a good place to to
to end I agree it's been a great
conversation
oh thank you Jonathan this was a joy
this was a joy I was looking forward to
it and it did not disappoint
and I'd love to do it again yeah
definitely we'll have to find a way when
I'm in Toronto to to meet in person as
well again yeah absolutely or or or vice
versa oh that's true you said you come
to Montreal yeah tell me when you're
wrong I do so yeah okay so we'll keep in
touch and we'll uh we'll make it happen
all right thanks for the conversation
thank you Jonathan all right you take
care all right